who are the rational
optimists I I came up with the term
rational Optimist I don't know if I did
but I don't know if I came up with the
theory but my idea was if you think the
future is just going to be great that's
not optimism that's complacency my my
definition of rational optimism was you
you think the future is going to be
better than it is today but the path
between now and then is going to be a
disaster it's going to be a constant
field of landmines and setbacks and
recessions and bare markets and
pandemics and wars and terrorist attacks
that you have to endure financially
psychologically career-wise in order to
get the reward of optimism on the other
end so it's like getting optimism and
pessimism to coexist that I think is
realistic optimism yeah it's like the
looking at Price goes from here to here
but it doesn't go like that price goes
from here to Here by going yeah of
course you see it in the stock market
where you know over a 10 or 20 year
period you can make a crazy amount of
money but in any given month in any
given week in any given year sometimes
even any given decade it's a disaster
and that's the price you have to pay in
order to get the the returns over 10 or
20 years so we went through some of your
book same as ever one of my favorite
things everyone needs to go and buy it
now it's super easy read very very
enjoyable next lesson I want to go
through is when the magic happens stress
focuses your attention in ways that good
times can't there's so many examples in
history of the world going through a
crazy tragedy Wars pandemics awful
things happen millions of people die and
then you look back 20 years later and
you realize that because of that
incident because of that war because of
that pandemic there was this crazy
amount of innovation and technology that
took place because people were panicked
and the incentives to innovate were off
the charts and you look back and you're
like look as terrible as that was we
created because of that all these
inventions that everyone benefits from
today the most technologically
Innovative period in I would say human
history took place in the 1930s and the
1940s the Great Depression and World War
II it started with the Great Depression
which was in analytical terms the
most like the the amount of productivity
that increased in 193s is more than any
other decade that's taken place because
it was all by necessity every single
business in America in the 1930s woke up
and they were like if we don't become
more productive today we're out of
business tomorrow so every business
learned how to become more efficient and
what came from that was the supermarket
laundromat all these new businesses that
were just designed to become more
efficient the um the factory line really
exploded during this period what Henry
Ford did with the factory line uh in the
1910s and 1920s every business took up
in the 1930s out of necessity World War
II comes along and the incentives that
happened because of that were just
completely off the charts during Good
Times boom times people's incentive to
innovate
is if I create a new product I might
become rich that's your incentive and
that's a good incentive you'll get
people moving in that world in the 1940s
it was if we don't innovate and figure
out new technologies Adolf Hitler is
going to control the entire planet that
was literally what was going on back
then so the scientific Community the
government businesses overnight they
were like all hands on deck we need to
innovate like there's no tomorrow and
what came out of that in a very short
period of time I mean I've summed it up
like this world war began in 1939 on
Horseback it ended in 1945 with nuclear
vision and what took place in those six
years what do we get out of it nuclear
energy Jets Rockets penicillin like all
of these things that benefit the world
in massive ways today and it
specifically happened because people
were panicked you can also Imagine a
world it's too early in which 20 years
from now we look back at covid and say
like look because of what happened in
2020 there was probably 30 years worth
worth of vaccine mRNA research and
understanding that got compressed into
like 6 months and you could imagine a
world it's so consistent with history
where we look back and we're like look
covid was terrible and shut the world
down and millions of people died but
look what we got out of it because of
this happened you could even say
something about work from home and like
just like the change in culture that
sped up during that period so it's kind
of this idea it's too much to say a
silver lining of World War II you don't
want to go that far it's a terrible
thing but it's this thing of like be
careful you wish for like Society
improves when the world is on fire not
when everyone's is happy and their
bellies are full and everyone's
gainfully employed that's when the magic
happens what what are the regular
elements of when the magic happens is it
uh being time bound is it people just
being panicked is there some sort of a
threat like what what are the uh
motivators I think it's the power of
incentives and mainly it's the downside
incentives when the economy is strong
you have positive incentives if I
innovate I might get rich if I don't
innovate I'll still probably be fine
when you have the Great Depression or a
war it's downside incentives it's if we
don't innovate we're all going to go out
of business we're all going to die we're
all going to be taken over that downside
incentives is what people it gets people
to be like oh [__] we need to go now
this is not a nice to have this is a
survival we need to go and so for
example in the 1940s during World War II
the scientific Community was like
literally digging through file cabinets
of like what are some like scientific
paper like what did we discover 30 years
ago what's this thing about splitting
atoms like let's try to do this one
right now and they just went full bore
and you see what humans are capable of
during a period like that now there's a
limit to it if you're if you are too
stressed under too much pressure it all
breaks down so not a lot of huge
scientific Innovations in the 1940s came
out of Europe with some exceptions but
that was too much trauma too much
tragedy the United States was like we
were panicked but there was not physical
destruction of our factories so like we
could keep it going what are the costs
that people pay for this
like there has to be a reason why we're
not moving at that pace all the time
despite the fact that it seems to give
great returns so there has to be some
sort of downside which is
disincentivizing people from doing it
when we're not facing a war or a
pandemic or a Great Depression I don't
know if there is a financial cost that
you could put to it but I think it is
that the opposite of stress induced
Innovation is when the economy is really
strong like right now and in relative
terms everyone becomes fat and happy and
they don't have the they don't wake up
every morning a little bit panicked I
mean I think most people will see this
in their individual lives where during a
recession even if you have a job you're
like I I this is kind of hanging by a
thread here I I got I got to really show
up early be the first one for the office
and work really hard in a way that you
don't tend to see that when everything
is going well so it's less about like
what I think the cost uh during Good
Times is just like the cost of of things
going well which is just like a lack of
urgency to get moving I mean the the
extreme example of this would be the
trust funer who has like no downside if
if if if they if they wake up and don't
innovate don't find a new job they're
fine nothing nothing bad is going to
happen to them and you see this in like
companies that are big and rich and
successful they kind of atrophy over
time and you compare that to the scrappy
startup it's night and day I had Mackin
Murphy who's a behavioral ecologist
halfway between uh behavioral economics
and evolutionary psychology sat in that
seat he was telling me that as the
economy gets worse the average BMI of
women in Playboy and centerold Mags goes
up and as the economy gets better the
BMI goes down so there is a relationship
between uh male preference for female
body size and resource scarcity if
during periods of Highly scarce
resources where the future is very
uncertain you see a woman that is able
to hold on to her body fat you think wow
I mean what an amazing hunter gatherer
she would be phenomenal to be with me
this would be great and they've done
this um in phenomenal study in canteen
Halls of universities and they would
show guys images of women before they
had dinner and then in different
iterations after they had dinner and
when they were hungry before they had
dinner they picked girls who were bigger
I mean this has been well known that
like in in way earlier times hundreds of
years ago thousands of years ago that
women who were a little bit heavier were
the more attractive ones they were the
healthier ones there were and the skinny
people were the ones who are like maybe
facing famine and then so it's it's a
pretty recent phenomenon of like a
preference for thinner women over time
that's a new thing one of my favorite
quotes from when the magic happens is
the same people with the same
intelligence have widely different
potential under different circumstances
this ability to sort of unlock that that
was already there yeah uh because of the
external pressure we were talking last
night about um uh good heart's law um
when a measure becomes an outcome it
ceases to be a good measure but a
similar one is Parkinson's law right uh
work will expand to fill the time given
for it yes and this is kind of like all
of these things
just coming down on top at the same time
I mean there's stories during World War
II when FDR would be like we need to
start producing 20,000 planes per year I
think was the number and everyone in the
room was like Mr President the absolute
maximum we can produce is 5,000 per year
and he was like 20,000 a year go do it
and they figured out a way to do it they
fig if they're like it's so cliche that
if there's a will there's a way but you
see what people are capable of during
those periods and again I think that's
that's been true for my life I'm been
sure it's true for your life during
during different periods of things are
going well or like I got some big risks
on my life right now what you are
actually capable of doing like changes
dramatically the uh biography the
Isaacson biography of musk I think can
be summarized as make insane Demand with
ridiculously short timeline and continue
to push people until it happens yeah
underd deliver a a little bit but only
by your own insane metric and what that
in is you overd delivering buing a
ridiculous margin yeah I know there's
stories of musk building particularly at
SpaceX where someone would come to him
and be like hey this part costs $3,000
and Elon will be like that part should
cost $20 you need to go build it and
they're like there's no way they're like
$20 go build just just like FDR and they
eventually figure it out like they
eventually do it and it makes you
realize like how much in life is an
artificial constraint of laziness of
like maybe that's the wrong word but
like a a good enough ism that if that is
taken away you realize you're capable of
literally multiple times what you think
you are overnight tragedies and
long-term Miracles good news comes from
compounding which always takes time but
bad news comes from a loss in confidence
or a catastrophic error that can occur
in the blink of an eye so think about
the really bad things that have happened
in modern times Pearl Harbor September
11th
Co they they literally happened in an
instant particularly Pearl Harbor in
9911 it was like one hour everything was
fine and the next hour the world had
gone to hell and there is no equivalent
of that with good news what is the good
news equivalent of Pearl Harbor in which
at 9 a.m. everything's okay and 10 a.m.
everything is amazing there's no
equivalent on the other end good news
tends to take a lot of time it tends to
play out slowly over the decades so one
of the best pieces of news to happen in
our in our modern times is the massive
decline in heart disease mortality it's
declined like more than 70% since the
1950s it has saved millions of lives cuz
we're better at controlling blood
pressure back in the 1950s if you had a
heart attack you're you're dead whereas
now if if you make it to the ER on time
there's a good chance you're going to
pull through they're going to get you
out of it made massive strides but we
tend to ignore that because what
happened is over the last 70 or 80 years
heart disease mortality improved like 2%
per year and in any given year you're
never going to hear about that there's
never going to be breaking news on the
New York Times Like heart disease
mortality improves by 70 basis points
you'll never hear about that but thead
news that happens quick you can't look
away from it and so I think it leaves
people more pessimistic than they should
be because they are constantly bombarded
by the bad news that happened very
quickly and you can't ignore and the
good news that is a slow compounding
over 50 years it's so easy to ignore
even if over time that good news is so
much more powerful at like improving
lives than the bad news that happens
quickly overnight tragedies and
long-term Miracles such a lovely
beautiful framing do you know the
difference in climat related deaths over
the last 100 years it's decreased by 50
times so much of it used to be called a
98% decline no this is through climate
Mastery so this is um people that live
in hot places being able to cool
themselves down and people that live in
cold places being able to warm
themselves up 98% reduction in the last
century of people dying from climate
right it makes perfect sense when you
say it and yet here look at all of the
people are dying from climate not to say
that climate change isn't something that
we need to address right but it's so
it's this overnight tragedies and
long-term Miracles exactly in a single
Incident That's occurring at the same
time yeah and you're like hang on a
second how can the climate related
Mastery reduction in deaths
be 50 times better like 98%
reduction
but it's also the worst thing in the
world and it's killing everybody in in
in poor countries it happen so slowly
you don't hear about it now there is
some bad news that plays out slowly over
time if you smoke cigarettes that's
that's like a slow compounding and
eventually the bad news might hit you in
a jerk when you die of lung cancer after
30 years toon but you're doing damage at
a slow rate maybe so would um climate
change moving forward as externalities
that might be an interesting one look at
all of this energy we've got look at how
we've fixed it and it's like ah yeah but
there's this like weird just number that
keeps ticking up the [__] CO2
PPI and the uh sea level and a
couple it's you know it's whatever but
that's the sort of thing that given
enough time would be a a long-term
tragedy yeah so there are a lot of those
things where by the time you do notice
it you're like oh okay that that that is
a big deal now now I can see it I get it
now why does bad news stick out so much
is it just because it's more Salient to
us I think it I mean it's always true
from an evolutionary perspective that
bad news is going to capture your
attention threats are going to capture
your attention more than opportunities
because in order to get the opportunity
you have to first survive the threat so
that's it's always been like that but I
think the biggest reason it occurs is
just like we said like the bad news is
happening so fast you can't look away
from it it's true in the stock market as
well there are historically over time
there have been days months weeks where
the stock market Falls 10% 20% during Co
the market fell 40% in four weeks
something like that very rarely if ever
that occur on the way up almost no
examples of the stock market Rising 40%
in one month will never happen so like
the ability to go down very quickly I
mean it's the classic cliche I think
it's um escalator up elevator down kind
of thing is usually how it works but I
think that's a good analogy for how a
lot of things work in life too it's just
like the speed at which they occur gets
your attention much much more tiny and
magnificent when little things compound
into extraordinary things I think it's
it's pretty common to think that a big
event in the world has to be caused by a
big action that if you're going to have
a major war a major recession it has to
be caused by something enormous that is
causing that thing to happen it's
usually not the case it's usually a
bunch of really small things that
interact in the right order that create
this massive event I mean this is
definitely true during the Great
Depression like the biggest economic
Calamity in the history of this country
and what was it caused by you had a
stock market crash well those happen all
the time you had a bank run those happen
all the time you had a dust bowl that
was like kind of un a dust bowl the Dust
Bowl was a period just around here in
the middle of the country where I mean
the backstory is uh after World War I or
during World War I farmers in the United
States were heavily incentiv and
incentivized to plant crops because we
were trying to feed the starving
Russians during this period so the US
government came in and said as much corn
as you can grow we'll buy it from you I
think it was $2 per bushel at the time
something like that so tons of farmers
that's a premium presumably it was huge
premium tons of farmers from all over
the country came to Kansas and Oklahoma
and just planted planted planted way too
much corn and they were terrible Farmers
they were just like plowing up land in
the most like voracious way that they
could and then it all kind of stopped
and they all bailed and left these
fallow fields to just sit there and kind
of uh dry up so they got Dusty and then
you had these massive dust storms that
would that pretty much wiped out a
region these dust storms that were just
like as apocalyptic as you could imagine
how did that impact the economy the
entire farming region in the Bread
Basket of the United States that was
producing all this was just wiped out I
mean literally just covered in dust uh
and wiped out I mean a huge portion of
the people and so many of those people
ended up just just abandoning it there
was no way you could make a living here
anymore so that happened at the same
time that you had a stock market crash
and a and a banking run all three of
those things individually would have
been bad but then happening at the same
time you get the Great Depression and I
think there's a lot of incidences like
that over time one of the most
interesting ones was during the 1950s
when we were experimenting with nuclear
weapons and this was the nuclear Age of
War we started to build really small
nuclear bombs the idea was yes we can
have a nuclear bomb that one bomb can
wipe out a city but we also want to use
this technology for more like tactical
Warfare and they came up with really
small bombs one of which you could
literally launch off of a shoulder fire
like bazooka and it would it was a
nuclear bomb but it was like a very low
yield so it would it do a lot of damage
but this was not like like thermonuclear
weapons and the idea was like oh great
like we can use these tactically there
was a joke that they even came up with a
nuclear hand grenade but they couldn't
find anyone dumb enough to throw it
which was the joke at the time but the
idea was that small nuclear weapons
would be safe to use but the actually
they were actually the riskiest thing in
the world because mutually assured
destruction was was a real thing and it
made it so that the Soviets and the
United States were not going to launch a
thermonuclear missile and wipe out a
city cuz the other would just retaliate
and the world gets wiped out but if you
had a small nuclear weapon that you were
going to use would you use that like the
barrier to using that was much lower but
then if the Soviets used a small nuclear
weapon on us would that justify us to
use a bigger one absolutely the Cuban
Missile Crisis in the 1960s the missiles
that Russia had uh you know lined up to
the United States point at the United
States were in order of magnitude lower
yield than what we we used in Japan
during World II way smaller the bombs
that they had but if they launched one
of those we would have retaliated with
the full force the biggest bombs that we
had so these like what created the
biggest risk in nuclear war were not the
big bombs it was the small bombs that we
were actually more likely to use and so
you have this tiny thing that we're like
oh it's a it's a nothing it's a nothing
Burger but that was going to be the
trigger to actual nuclear warfare I just
read this recently this is not in the
book the guy who invented the machine
gun his last name was Gatling the
Gatling gun uh he actually invented it
with the idea that the machine gun would
end all wars because it was so
destructive and has it was such a
killing machine that every country would
look at it and be like we can't go to
war we're just all going to get wiped
out it's too deadly now and so you have
all these things that do you know Mr
Gatling beginning of it you won't
believe what happened next yeah yeah
yeah and so you have all these things
where someone creates something that
they either think is small or they're
like oh it's not that big of a deal to
use it but it just like compounds into a
much bigger thing so fascinating so the
takeway from all that to me is like
people underestimate the odds of big
events because you think a massive
recession needs to be caused by like an
economic meteor and it doesn't it can be
like five small events compounding at
the same time in just the right order
that set offs a chain reaction but this
is evolution as well right this is how
you go from single cell eukariotic to
procaryotic or the other way around
bacteria in a vent somewhere to mean you
that in front of microphones having chat
yeah it's never yeah and like I think if
you are a skeptic of evolution it's
because you think you make the jump of
like how do we go from a frog into a
human that makes no sense but you're
like well if you have 0.000000 infinite
change in every generation and you
compound that for a billion years then
you get something great it's like the
tiniest little thing for a massive
amount of time you get something amazing
Elation and despair progress requires in
optimism and pessimism to coexist I
hearing this story from Admiral
Stockdale who was um the highest ranking
uh p in Vietnam and he was talking after
he was released he was talking about how
some of the PS behaved when they were in
prison and he said do you know who did
the worst as a p it was the Optimus
because the Optimus would say we're
going to be home by Christmas and then
Christmas would come and go and they
were just crushed they were just
destroyed and he said the people who did
the best were like
the rational optimists as I would Define
it it' be people who would say we're
going to go home by no no I'm sorry they
would say we're going to go home
eventually this war is going to end and
we're you're going to see your wife
again but we're not going home by
Christmas no one's going home by this is
going to be a long War that's who
actually did the best like they could
take optimism and pessimism at the same
time and put them together and be a
rational Optimist another great example
of this in business is Bill Gates who in
the 1970s when he started Microsoft took
the biggest optimistic swing any
entrepreneur has ever taken and by
saying like there's going to be a
computer on every desk in the world like
the craziest bold Vision anyone's ever
taken at the same time he managed
Microsoft as conservatively as you
possibly could in terms of like tons of
cash on the balance sheet no debt he
always said that he wanted enough cash
in the bank so that Microsoft could make
payroll for one year with no Revenue the
most conservative way you can run a
business at the same time he's taking
this ridiculous swing for the fence
and I think there are so many other
businesses that are just as good if not
better at creating products than
Microsoft might be but they were
managing the business with an equal
level of optimism of like Leverage and
debt and they eventually just get wiped
out they run themselves over a cliff so
Gates could take massive optimism and
crazy pessimism and be like these things
are going to coexist at the same time
and that's an analogy for how a lot of
people do well over time like the person
like the pure Optimus runs over a cliff
the pure p never gets out of bed the
person who knows when each needs to come
into play is who actually does well over
time what's that Talib thing about uh
like I'm an authoritarian with my family
I'm a socialist with my community I'm a
communist with my Village she says at
the federal level I'm a Libertarian at
the state level I'm a republican at the
local level I'm a Democrat and at the
family level I'm a socialist it's such a
brilliant I think it's a great thing to
say like as the size of something thing
changes what you expect out of it and
your relationship with it also changes
it's also your nature must be able to
adapt to the demands of the situation
that you're in and the vertical that
you're in okay so a business is not just
a thing this amorphous thing it's not
just Tesla doesn't just make cars and
invent [__] it also has to make money
and like pay payroll and and be in
compliance and it deals with lawsuits
and it does all of these other things
it's like do you really want Elon
steaming into the lawsuit department for
the person that's just been run over by
an autonomous car probably not that's
where you have different horses for
different courses yes right and this is
I
suppose the difficulty comes when you as
an individual agent try to amalgamate
all of this into one brain you know in
an organization you can specialize you
can chunk things down you find the
person that has the nature that you want
we want to be conservative in the
accounting department we want to be
creative in the advert
fantastic like don't get those the other
way or else you end up with
borings and a huge problem with
entrepreneurship is the assumption that
because you can understand a technical
product that you know how to run the
business of a technical product it's
pretty rare so someone like Mark
Zuckerberg is very rare he had the
technical chops to build Facebook build
it himself and to run it today as a
trillion dollar company that's very rare
it's way more common for you to be an
entrepreneur who knows how to build a
product and then as soon as it's scales
you're like I don't know what I'm doing
here I need to call in the big boys who
know what they're doing I mean a good
example of that was Uber where Travis
like no one could have built Uber other
than Travis kenck his ability to take a
risk his willingness to just give the
middle finger to The Regulators was like
no one else was willing to do that and
once Uber became a big company probably
nobody was worse at running a a company
than Travis C because that same attitude
of like [__] The Regulators we're just
going to do our thing once Uber was a
hundred billion doll company that's not
the guy you running you can't play the
game so it's so but that's more common
to have like a different like the person
who has right to run it at this size is
not the person who's right to run it at
this size I told you the story of Ben
Francis last night and I mentioned that
Ben was founder founder CEO stepped back
as CEO guy that used to run pummer or
Reebok came in then Ben came in as like
CBO or something like something to do
with brand or like some sort of
consultant steep back then came back in
as CEO and he said this thing on the
podcast that really struck with me and
he
said when your Ambitions for the brand
are bigger than your Ambitions for
yourself that's when you'll become
successful I like that that he was
prepared to be like hey am I the best
person for the job right now yes okay
let's not to 10 mil let's do that do I
have the first idea about how to run a
20 million pound business not really
incomes the person from Reebok we're now
at a $3 billion business well you know
maybe it's actually there's different
chance ches and it's useful for me to be
back and he was just completely prepared
to put his own ego to one side and say
what am I supposed to do so that shows a
person who is right at multiple
different stages but not right at all
stages yeah I think there's a
interesting alternative history in which
Steve Steve Jobs does not die in 2011
and keeps running Apple what would Apple
be today because the truth is after he
left and T Tim Cook came in apple did
great Apple did phenomenal in terms of
like unit sold like net income Apple has
absolutely thrived under Tim Cook and I
think You' actually make the argument
that around the time that Steve Jobs
happened to die what Apple the company
actually needed was a Tim Cook because
and and what they needed before that was
Steve Jobs like in the early 2000s you
needed a crazy maniac like Steve Jobs to
come in and be like I got this crazy
idea for new products and no one else is
thinking of that's what Apple needed
once they came up with those products
what you needed was someone to come in
and keep the trains moving on time like
Tim Cook so there is a weird alternative
history and I'm I'm totally making this
up it's anyone's guess Steve Jobs
doesn't die he keeps running apple and
into the ground yes yes I I actually
don't think that's likely but I think
it's like a very real possibility that
could have happened you could it depends
what metric you want do you want to
continue to have this sort of pioneering
spirit this person that's just doing
like out there doing crazy things and
it's exciting and all the rest of it
yeah in the beginning yes my my hot take
of shared with some people and I say
this tongue and- cheek I'm not actually
making this bet uh within 5 years Elon
Musk will either be a trillionaire or
bankrupt and there's like 5050 odds of
either it's that's my hot take I don't
actually take it that seriously but he's
the kind of person who is like
completely incapable of slowing down
it's always just bigger bet bigger bet
bigger bet bigger bet and eventually
that might that usually catches up with
people um but it's so fascinating to
watch while he's doing it yeah yeah it
really is uh one of my friends that
lives here in Austin
was working for a company that recruited
the highest level seite Executives so
they didn't play Susanna was jiy uh or
Tim Cook but they uh went through the
process with both of them and what he
was able to do he had access to their
internal company interet and every
archive and he was able to go in and see
the biggest Executives in the world and
see what their recruiters were saying
after they'd had this sit down and I was
like this is fu fascinating tell me what
did you read and he said well there's a
difference between the a players and the
AAA players said the a players are in
there and there's you know the usual
stuff and there's often something that
pops up that's maybe a little bit of a
concern but they're they're good they're
well-rounded he said but the AAA players
are 10 times better and they stand out
as that as well I think in um Tim cck's
the first two words were absolute stud
were the first two words of Tim Cook uh
Susanna was a rockar was like one of the
first few sentences and you think it's
very interesting like these
people they're more than just like again
I don't know much about either of the
guys but from the conversation I had
they're more than just business people
yeah there's something like ineffable in
them where people who are exposed to the
best talent the best paid most high
placed Talent on the planet for the
biggest companies in the world look at
them and go stud Rockstar yeah and I
think like back to Apple like once Steve
Jobs invented the amazing products the
next step is okay can we literally make
a billion iPhones and keep the quality
as high as they need to be and that's
what you needed a Tim Cook for and I
don't know if Steve Job would have had
that skill to keep that going but you
could also Imagine a world which he
doesn't die and as everyone knows the
last 10 iterations of iPhones have been
exactly the same and that would not have
been the case under Steve Jobs they
would have it would have kept innovating
and created new things casualties of
perfection there is a huge advantage to
being a little
imperfect I think it's always the case
that people want to squeeze as much
opportunity as they can out of
everything in life uh whether it's in
your career whatever it might be and
that invariably is going to eventually
catch up to you like room for error in
what you're doing is a massively
important thing to have you saw this in
2021 where in manufacturing all over the
world the biggest Trend over the last 20
years was efficient efficient efficient
Just in Time Manufacturing and then 2021
rolls around and there's a little bit of
like what is was honestly like a hiccup
in the global uh in global T gets stuck
in the [__] thingy Canal everything
collaps everything breaks there was no
leeway whatsoever for anything to go
wrong in the system and you can imagine
a world in which those companies that
were doing just in time manufacturing
and then like collapsed in 2021 if they
had actually help a little bit more
inventory in their warehouses their Roi
would have been a little bit lower in
2019 but they would have actually been
able to supply products in 2021 and so
it's always a case that like having a
little bit of room for error having a
little bit of leeway is great and it's
true in your personal life too most
people these days have what I call
thought jobs their job is to work with
their head it's not to dig a ditch or
like pull a lever their job is to make a
decision with something and in that
world what you really need more than
anything else is time to think time to
ponder time to like figure out a problem
in your head and what does that look
like it looks like sitting on the couch
it looks like going for a walk it
doesn't look like work but most bosses
will not allow that most bosses even if
you have a thought job is like I need
you at your desk moving your fingers on
the keyboard eight hours a day and so
they don't have any time in their day
for something that looks inefficient but
is actually going to be like the thing
that's actually critical to their job
yeah Rory southernland has this idea
about no one gets fired for hiring KPMG
yeah which is the safe bet following the
blueprint doing the thing that signals
busyness to a lot of people look at my
average response time on slack that's
really good and it's like yeah but did
we hire you as a slack reper yeah is
that your job to be the slack response
guy or is your job to be so George one
of my good friends his first job uh at
Social chain they literally created a
role for him they called him innovation
lead I was like that's like vague what's
that mean don't know not sure what they
just make a make a rooll for him put him
in there he'll do something cool he used
to go uh this was uh Steven bartler talk
company and they had all of these
different big fan pages so they were
able to design social media marketing
campaigns but they were also able to
deploy them because they had the
pipeline they had a a two million person
Harry Potter fan group or whatever it is
and um George found that it was one of
these open plan offices with [__]
AstroTurf everywhere and there's a slide
in a ball pit you like one of the
classic sort of mid 2000s e type things
and um George hated working in it didn't
like the open plan office way too
distracting he needs a little bit more
order uh so he found that there was a
room upstairs all of these different
places filming content there was a room
upstairs where they were trying to build
the world's largest Harry Potter jigsaw
puzzle but no one could be bothered
doing it and it was like there was no
time limit on the product uh the project
to be completed and to be filmed so he
would go up stairs and sit on the floor
in this empty room that was 40 ft by 40t
with no one in it no desk no nothing
just a laptop on the floor and bits of
Harry Potter jigsa around him that he
wasn't allowed to move because that
would like wreck the continuity but he
would go upstairs and sit surrounded by
[__] Harry Potter jigsaw puzzle
pieces but that was his thing yeah his
thing was I don't want to be the slack
response guy that's not I want actually
make a decision on something that's my
thing you're a big Walker I'm a big
Walker virtually every I mean whenever I
write a book or an article that was
written during a walk like I don't think
very well if I'm sitting at my desk
being like okay time to be creative time
to working doesn't doesn't happen you
get good ideas in the shower you get
good ideas going for a walk going for a
run at the gym that's when things happen
so people I think people intuitively
understand that you need unstructured
time in your day where you should just
have like a 4-Hour Block in your
calendar that says thinking time but but
you you can't do that it's because
everyone wants to like squeeze
efficiency and opportunity out of their
calendar
yeah I had uh I release each year the
same annual template that I've done to
do my end of year review and uh I have
to admit that this year even though I
sent out the one that I've done for five
years I actually changed it so I did a
completely different process and I love
the new one that I did so that will be
available next year for the people that
are listening and I asked myself a
really interesting question I thought it
was [__] interesting which was uh
what do I think is productive but isn't
what do I do that I think is productive
but isn't uh other stuff like what would
I do if I wanted to make 85y old me
miserable what are the things I would
continue doing what would I do if I
wanted to make 85-year-old me what would
85-year-old me wish that I did more of
what do I think is productive that isn't
calls slack and WhatsApp yeah staying in
on weekends sitting at my desk when I'm
not working what is productive that I
don't realize dinners with new people
attending events travel reading that's
so good like what you think is
productive but isn't is like things that
look like work and what is productive
are things that don't look like work
like most people would be like oh going
out for dinner that's just pleasure
that's just like last night last night
two chapters probably from you for my
new book and a couple of quotes from me
for yours and so Chris you and I had
dinner last night for two or three hours
and I think both of us got tons of idea
for Content way more than I've done by
sitting down on my desk trying to R if I
had and if I had skipped dinner and just
sat in my hotel trying to work I would
have come up with absolutely nothing
yeah but it's so hard for people
particularly if they are employed by a
company to do that because if you tell
your boss hey I need a budget to go out
with to go out to dinner with my smart
friends three times a week and I need to
expense that and that's G to pay off go
[__] yourself you need to sit at your
desk and type and every boss thinks that
that's what's so hard and I think that's
also why it's very difficult to innovate
within a company like what looks like
productive work uh is not what's
actually what's actually productive
worth I wonder whether this is good
Hearts Laur again when a measure becomes
an outcome it ceases to a good measure
if an organization that gets to a
particular size starts to be broken down
anything that can ever be seen on a
dashboard is dangerous because it
removes all of the things that can't be
seen on a dashboard which for the most
part are the things that are the highest
outliers in terms of your return in any
case yeah like we I was telling you this
idea of hidden observable metrics last
night and a lot of the creativity and
the biggest outlier um returns that
you're going to get are going to come
from hidden metrics they're going to be
driven by hidden metrics not observable
metrics like yeah sure your um editor
for your book probably needs to be
observable metrics guy like how many
hours changes did you make how many
times did you look at this one sentence
how much red ink did you use on
manuscript yeah yeah yeah Jeff Bezos
talked about this recently on on on a
podcast where he's like a lot of metrics
within businesses maybe they made sense
at one point but then people just keep
using them and you're using the same
metric and people don't ask like does
this metric actually lead to success or
is this just what we're been trained
what we've been told to do and that's
that's a lot of it too so like there
might be some point in your career in
which calls were productive there might
like very early in your career like your
job is to cold call like the number of
calls you did but if you keep that for
the rest of your career like you need to
change the metrics in what you're
following that's why I I think that it
is a it's an error for people to not see
the advantage of saying yes to someone
that comes through town someone's coming
through town they're in your town maybe
they're only in your town for like 2
hours they a layover or something but
they're allowed to leave the airport and
maybe you can grab a coffee with them
[__] go for the coffee with them like
say yes to meeting new people dude I had
I I stayed with Douglas Murray you know
Douglas is uh British uh political
commentator author journalist I stayed
with him in New York uh January two
years ago when I first moved out to
America and I spent 3 days in Manhattan
with him in his in his
apartment that
three-day period uh didn't do much for
my li because he likes to have
cocktails but I I [__] you not it came
up with like six lifechanging insights
that I still think about at least weekly
I feel like I can get that from a single
book or a single podcast too and it's a
constant reminder to me that what does
good look what does good work look like
for me sitting on the couch in my
sweatpants with a book that's the most
productive thing that I can possibly do
but even after doing this for 18 years
I still feel like I'm not working when I
do that it's it's really hard to
actually switch your mindset into being
to saying that's what I need to do I was
telling you before that Rob Henderson's
one of my favorite people he was Sting
that seat not long ago as well and he
his most popular substack article of
last year given that he's done 5,000
word 10,000w breakdowns of advanced
sociopsychological
textbooks and all this sort of stuff was
a thousand-word blog post called how I
read and he's he got this one line in it
which is reading is like going to the
gym you must dedicate time to it and I
think for me still now I think oh
reading's like somewhere between a
relaxation activity a Leisure activity
and something I do when I have spare
time yeah I don't think that about the
gym I think the gym is the thing that I
make myself go and do so a lot of people
get frustrated at the fact that they
don't read enough first off they should
download my reading list which you can
get at chrisw x.com books and psychology
and money's in it second thing that they
should do is actually commit some
[__] time
you have to because your reading time
and this is me shouting at
me your reading time is always going to
be the important thing that gets pushed
to the side by the Urgent thing there's
always going to be more slack messages
there's always going to be another
[__] invoice to reply to there's
always going to be emails or a call to
take or something that you need to do or
a [__] dinner that you need to get
ready for and you say no I can't I've
I've got a gym session at that time can
we do it an hour later no I can't I'm
busy at that time like might be a bit
odd to say like push dinner back cuz I'm
reading but like that's the philosophy
that you need to have going into it I'll
tell you how this impacts me um my wife
bless her she's wonderful if I'm sitting
at my desk typing she's like oh Morgan's
working I can't bother him I I I work
from home I have a glass door in my
office so she can see it if I'm on the
couch reading she's like oh he's not
working can you come help me fold the
laundry this kind of thing like her her
her bar for interrupting me if I'm
reading is so much lower than if I'm
typing and I don't blame her for that
like what looks like you're working is
not what what what is actually
productive it's supposed to be hard
everything worth pursuing comes with a
little pain the trick is not minding
that it hurts there's this great scene
in Lawrence of Arabia where a guy uh
pulls out a a match lights it up and
puts it out with his fingers doesn't
even wi this other guy watching him he's
like oh let me try that pulls out the
match lights it up puts his fingers on
and goes ah it hurts what's the trick
and Lawrence goes the trick is not
minding that it hurts and it's like is
such such a brilliant scene and that
applies to almost everything like there
is a cost to pay for almost anything and
a trick in almost any Endeavor in life
is figuring out what the cost is and
just being willing to pay it it's true
in investing of putting up with
volatility it's true in your career
where there's a Jeff Bezos quote where
he says like look if you can get to the
point in your career where you enjoy
half of it where half of it is fun
that's I guess good as it gets like
there's things in any job that just suck
it's like dumb boring admin work and if
you can get to where half of it is fun
that's great you and I were talking
about this last night in both of our
careers a lot of it is fun and very
fulfilling a lot of it is kind of just
manal and just work uh it's just capital
W work so I think in almost anything
figuring out the cost of it is is the
most vital part of of being successful
over time and you see this a lot in
people's careers you and I were talking
about this last night take someone who
was Uber successful uh musk Gates
Zuckerberg those kind of people if you
actually drill into what it took for
them to aeve a that success Michael
Jordan Kopi LeBron all those kind of
people the cost that they paid to get
that success in their personal life
often for their health for their mental
well-being is off the charts but it's so
common for us to look at them and be
like I want that life I could have that
looks like an amazing life but when you
actually factor in the cost of what it
took you're like I don't know I don't
know it's the thing that I've been the
most obsessed by I would say from uh uh
other people Psych ology perspective
over the last two years uh Tiger Woods
perfect example of this uh I had an
entire bit in my live show about this
James Joyce you know masterful author
but post humously a long series of fart
fetish love letters that he W wrote to
his wife were released on the internet
like uh Salvador doly you know much
about Dary complete
Maniac his parents gave birth to a child
10 months before him that they called
Salvador and then almost immediately got
pregnant again that one died they were
Adam that Dary was The Reincarnation of
his dead older brother that's how you
entered the world uh when he was a child
Dar pressure throw himself down the
stairs he found out that he was a
masochist very early in life he would
throw himself down the stairs for fun
when he was giving a lecture he was
suffocating inside of a deep sea diving
suit that he had to be wrenched out of
mid talk while he was giving a lecture
he married a woman who was married at
the time they were both married they
both separated ated from their current
Partners got together and then darly
immediately started to treat her as
halfway between a God and royalty so he
bought her a castle and then would send
formal letters of request asking to
visit her in the castle that he bought
her uh and who would refer to her as his
Muse and all the rest of it but all of
those things contributed to that's how
you end up painting like melon clocks
and then stuff like that yeah as
brilliant as he was Da Vinci didn't do
Dary and Michelangelo didn't do Dary
yeah the only way we get is by being the
throw myself down the stairs lock myself
inside of the deep sea diving suit
buying my future wife a castle person
that's the only way there's a a quote
from Alex that I spoke to him about the
start of last year it's one of my
favorite ones whenever I get to a low
point where I think why do I even bother
I just try to remind myself this is
where most people stop and this is why
they don't win a reminder for the
Gladiators in the arena who feel beat up
and scarred with no hope in sight
building a business business is hard
hard feels shitty this is what hard
feels like and this is why most people
can't do it but you can this is what
hard feels like was in my memo that I
sent to the team this year it's
something he told me this great story
about when uh pledges he was in a
fraternity at at college and he was like
high up or whatever uh the pledges were
whining about what they were being made
to do and he said right I know
everyone's having a pity party here so
he calls them around and he says look
who here thought that this was going to
be easy no one puts their hands up he's
like who here thought that this was
going to be hard like everyone puts
their hands up and he goes this is what
hard feels like no I think in most
Endeavors in life people perfectly
understand the relationship between
price and quality you want a nicer car
it cost more bigger house it costs more
but that like understanding goes out the
window when you're talking about Career
Success or career fulfillment or
personal health things like that like
that the the relationship just kind of
breaks down in their own mind but it it
doesn't go away like the higher the
success the higher the cost I love
reading biographies of entrepreneurs of
generals whoever it might be with very
few exceptions do I finish the biography
and think to myself I want that person's
life what I think is I'm glad they
existed I'm so glad the world had that
person that we can all benefit from but
though the crazy success comes with a
cost that very few people including most
of the time myself are not willing to
pay how can people not mind that it
hurts more I think when you talk about
someone like Dolly it's like it's ingra
it's ingrained in them I think some I
think whenever you have somebody like
musk Zuckerberg Jordan Tiger Woods it
was not a decision that they made they
had to they had to pursue it's a
compulsion um several years ago I heard
Patrick oesi say that the single word
that he would describe for most
successful people was not driven it's
not motivated it's tortured that they
wake up every morning just like I I'm
tortured at at the success that I have
not achieved yet and I have to I have to
go do this I have to go work 24 hours so
some people I think are born with it and
some people are not which is why like
the success is so stratified um once in
a while I think you have someone who is
like a middling success and became a
Founder at age 50 and knocked it out of
the park but that's extremely rare I
think it's usually people who for whom
this is just in their blood they have to
do it yeah again from Alex last year he
said Champions are broken people look at
Champions and try to find something they
have that everyone else doesn't have but
it's the wrong way round Champions don't
have something that everybody else does
have a sense of a sense of being
fulfilled correct and saying like that's
enough what was the Donna party the
Donner party was this amazing and see
for you you you as as a Brit probably
never heard of the Donner Party is that
right no so back in in the 1800s there
was a pretty well wealthy family the
Donner Clan they were in Chicago who
were moving West as a lot of people were
and the Don like they were very very
wealthy but they were like driven to the
the wealth and the opportunity and the
prosperity of California which is the
new land during this period so they
start making it out west and this is of
course before railroads are making out
on on Wagon Train and they start off
there's a very big party it's more than
150 of them that start off and at one
point they meet I think they're in the
middle of Nevada and they meet this
quack who promises them a shortcut who
says like hey like the route between
here and to pass through the Sierra
Nevada mountains is pretty tough but I
know a shortcut you can make your way
around here the shortcut turned out
ended up being completely bogus and it
was it was nonsense they Bally had to
basically backtrack back to where they
originally started from that delay made
it so now they were going to cross the
Sierra Nevada mountains in the middle of
the winter which is not when you want to
be doing it you want to cross it in the
summer or the fall before the snow comes
they eventually hit the Sierra NADA
mountains during what was the biggest
winter in decades the biggest snow dump
they got completely stuck and they had
to resort to eating each other
cannibalism and it's a it's absolutely
horrific Story I mean one of the details
that sticks out from there that just
shows like the plight that they were in
when they were eating each other and
there were still dozens of them alive at
this point they would label the meat
that was harvested to make sure that you
did not have to eat your sister or your
mother that you were eating somebody
else's I mean the plate that they went
through was extraordinary and two things
have always like stuck out for me from
the daughter party most people just
focus on that element of the story one
of the things that stucks out is sticks
out is that they were they were already
rich they were not going to
because they're like we're broke and we
want new they were they were just like
seeking more they were already crushing
it the other was they were in this
situation specifically because they were
El like tempted by a shortcut and look
I'm all for efficiency I'm all for doing
things the right way but so many
shortcuts are just cutting Corners
that's eventually going to backfire
around you and they were like such a
profound example of that the safest way
to get what you want is to try to
deserve what you want that was from
manga what's that mean he he he he
mentioned this in several different
contexts the biggest that he mentioned
it in was love if you want to be loved
the way that you get that is deserve to
be loved uh there's another quote from
my friend Brent bore when he's like he
says something along the lines of
marriage works when both you and your
spouse devote your life to serving the
other person and expect nothing in
return so you wake up and you're like
I'm here to serve my wife and I don't
expect her to serve me back if both of
you do that at the same time you're both
serving each other without expecting
anything else in return It's Magic think
about what the opposite of that is Neil
Strauss said this the other week
un unspoken expectations are
premeditated
resentments unspoken expectations
premeditated exctly I think that's a
Brent's exact point said more succinctly
yeah that's that's really what it is so
I think you know now and I think it's a
trueu for a lot of things if you want to
be wealthy like you need to deserve it
if you want to be a successful
entrepreneur you need to deserve it no
shortcuts it's all just like find the
price and pay pay it keep running most
competitive advantages eventually die I
think there's so many examples of this
one of the most interesting is Sears uh
which if you go back to the 70s and 80s
no other company in America had the moat
that Sears did it was completely
Unstoppable SE for the Brits oh are you
kidding me come on Sears was kind of the
uh it was it was the most successful
retailer mostly clothes and things like
that department store but they also sold
um you know washing machines that kind
of they're actually still around like a
walm type thing yes but less big than
you know less uh less all-encompassing
than Walmart but they were everywhere
they were so dominant back in the day
nobody could touch them and they got so
big that they started by they bought
Discover card and like Dean Witter stock
they started like moving into all these
other areas no other it was truly the
Walmart of its day or even like the
apple of its day I was just like nobody
compete with this and then they lost
everything and went bankrupt and then
lost it and if you dig back into what
happened of like they became SU
successful because they were so Scrappy
and so terrified of of competitors
that's why they became successful as
soon as they got big it all went to
their head and they were like we're
Sears nobody compete with us they
stopped innovating they ignored this
upcomer that was chasing them called
Walmart completely ignored it and by the
time that they realized what had
happened it was way too late they were
gone and I think that's actually a very
common story that it happens in
individual's lives as well where the
reason that you are working so hard is
so that eventually one day you will
achieve a level of success in which you
don't have to work so hard anymore
that's what's motivating you is the
dream that you can one day relax so when
you become successful you justifiably
think I can stop working so hard I don't
need to grind as hard anymore and then
the moment you think that and it's
Justified you think it's Justified you
you lose what actually made you
successful to begin with and then it's
that's the downfall and you see like
there's this amazing interview many
years ago with Mike meritz who was the
head of of seoa the most successful
Venture Capital firm that's ever existed
and Charlie Rose asked him he said why
has seoa been so successful for 40 years
not over one market cycle you've
dominated for 40 years and Mike Merit
said we've always been scared of going
out of
business and like look if there's anyone
in Silicon Valley who has the right to
say it's because we're smart it's
because we're so good at what we do he
has the right to say that but he didn't
say that he said we're terrified of
going out of
business like like like you never let
your guard down what made you successful
you never let go of that isn't re
Business book only the paranoid survive
that's it exactly and uh you know
there's I think there's lots of
different versions of this I read
recently that The Unofficial motto of
Nvidia their unofficial corporate motto
is we are always 30 days from going out
of business that's what they tell
themselves in their meetings we're
always 30 days from going out bus
hanging over that yes but I think that's
why they're that's at least one of the
reasons why they're so successful what
me and you were talking about this last
night and I think it's a brilliant frame
and I want to spend more time building
it out uh serotonin Morgan versus
dopamine Morgan and I think that the
only the paranoid survive business model
is uh dopamine company not serotonin
company yeah right that is very Vigilant
very anxious very on edge making sure
that everything scru heavily
scrutinizing all of the different
options and keeping a breast of of
competitors and and you know having
these sort of underlying resentments but
also knowing that I can't really bring
them up because that's also not going to
be good but I'm going to [__] hate
them in any case yeah it's that energy
it's that leanin it's that tentative
sort of very watchful energy and I think
that especially if you are somebody
that's
close not only close to the operating of
a business but also emotionally invested
in the operating of a business or if
your professional life and your personal
life have Blended in a way it can be
very difficult to not have what is
effective professionally curse you
personally yeah right it is very very
good for you to be on edge in that
manner very good it is useful and
effective as a business to be on edge in
that manner yeah it is catastrophic and
destructive for you to be on edge in
that same way in your private life and
what's so hard is that most people when
they make a mistake don't know it
they're blind to it whereas cutting back
because you become successful is a
cognizant decision you know that you're
like I because I've become successful I
can now sleep in I can now work fewer
hours you know you're doing it you think
it's Justified but what you are blind to
is like what that's actually going to do
to your career and someone tweeted this
just last week they said when does a
startup lose its magic and the precise
moment when it happens for every one of
these companies is when the CEO stops
building the product when the CTO stops
coding when the chief marketing officer
is not writing the the the copy anymore
it's like once you become so big that
the senior executives are detached from
actually doing the work when the
musician stops writing their own songs I
know authors who when they become big uh
they have so much pressure and incentive
to write more books that they basically
hire ghost riters or at least people to
the and that's when you lose the magic
you're not doing it yourself anymore the
same thing is so true in the world of
podcasting and specifically YouTube
YouTube more than podcasting uh the
creators that take their eye off the
ball with guest booking guest research
scheduling titles thumbnails and
branding what actually matters the
longest points of Leverage like if I I
spend six hours every single week on
calls just doing copyrighting for seven
videos that's it so it's an hour of
video we spend an hour of video to come
up with the right title in the right
thumbnail because it's one of the
longest levers that we have yeah every
single video that's ever gone out I've
touched every and I'm like getting to
the stage now I was telling you this
last night I'm I want to operationalize
things I'm tired like I don't get to
just do the things that I used to do but
I also realize and this is uh Leila hosi
Alex's wife um I asked her what are the
things that you should Outsource and one
of the things that you shouldn't one of
the first things that she said you
shouldn't Outsource the thing that makes
the money or the impact yeah yes yes
that's good Outsource everything else
[__] get a maid get a cleaner get a
gardener get a [__] driver get a
whatever you need but don't Outsource
the thing that you're there to do yeah I
think you see this a lot in um in
investing where you have someone who's a
very talented investor very good at
picking stocks finding the right
business and then they launch a fund
what ises launching a fund entail half
your time is going to be fundraising
half your time is going to be accounting
HR you got to hire people and then
you're completely detached from what
actually made you good to begin with and
that is so common in any
business I I think it's I think it's I
think if you like identifying that point
if you can effectively Outsource those
kind of things I think if you are the
entrepreneur the CEO whoever it is and
you get to a point where you're like hey
I've become really successful and I I
became this successful because I wanted
to step back you need to be honest with
yourself and DET and remove yourself
from the situation the people who fall
into problems are like I grinded for 20
years now I'm successful but I'm not
going to leave this business that I
built I'm going to stay here and just
become fat happy and lazy that's when it
eventually just crumbles yeah the
wonders of the future it always feels
like we're falling behind and it's
always easy to Discount the potential of
new technology it's so like very rare is
there a single new invention that is
amazing in and of itself it's usually
that you have a small invention and then
10 years later another small invention
20 years later another small invention
and those things come together and
that's what creates something amazing
Jeff basos talked about this recently
where he was like when he launched
Amazon in the 1990s he did not need to
build a payment system it already
existed it was called Visa MasterCard he
didn't need to create a shipping system
it already existed it was ups but like
he took all of those things and combined
them and built on top of them and it's
true for a lot of Innovations of like I
mean the the most like stunning example
is Thomas Edison did not invent the
light bulb it was first invented by a
guy Nam uh named Humphrey Davies who was
a Brit who created something that looked
exactly like the light bulb I think 20
years before Thomas Edison the
difference was the light bulb that he
built it was impossibly bright you would
go blind by looking at it and and it
would only stayform what can I say and
it would only stay lit for like 5
Seconds what Edison did is he moderated
the intensity and he lengthened the
endurance of the light bulb that was in
incredible but let's not pretend that he
built that flaming bulb from scratch he
didn't he took what other people had
done and built on top of it and it's
true for almost any invention of like
obviously uh obviously Henry and Ford
did not invent the engine he didn't
invent the the wheel he just like
combined all of these things so whenever
a new invention comes out I think it's
very easy to be like what is this useful
for and a lot of times the answer is
like we don't know but someone like this
is going to be something that somebody
combines with other things in the future
that's going to become something
incredible you've got a typical path of
how people respond to what eventually
becomes world changing new technology
first I've never heard of it then I've
heard of it but I don't understand it I
understand it but I don't see how it's
useful I see how it could be fun for
rich people but not me I use it but it's
just a toy it's becoming more useful to
me I use it all the time I could not
imagine life without it seriously people
lived without it it's too powerful and
needs to be regulated and it's true for
almost every like big invention the two
that are most interesting to me was the
invention of the car and the airplane
which when both of those came out in the
early 1900s the first reaction to those
was like I don't understand why anyone
would want this the first car was so
inferior to the horse and the first
plane was so inferior to the train so
everyone looked at it and they're like
what the hell is the use and then it was
like oh I see it's a rich person's toy
if you're if you're a zillionaire you're
going to have a car that you can putter
around town with I kind of get it and
then it becomes better and better both
the car and the plane the first uses
that people saw for it was like oh we
could strap a machine gun to this and
use it in the Army virtually nobody saw
even the people who worked in those
Industries what it would become which
was like good for transporting people
and like nobody saw with the car they're
like oh this is going to open up a new
form of living called the suburbs and
people can drive to the city now nobody
saw those things coming it was a very
long path it usually takes 10 to 20
years at least before people are like oh
now I get it you saw this too there's so
many classic examples of in the 1990s of
Articles Written In Time Magazine about
like the internet why would anyone want
to use the internet how could anyone
possibly like lug around this thing
called a laptop nobody's ever going to
do that and and it's easy to poke fun at
those and you should poke fun at them
but it's actually common for virtually
every new technology that you cannot
fathom what it's going to eventually
become how should
we interpret this consistent Trend
should we be less quick to cynicism and
skepticism around things it's also very
common historically that people say we
haven't had a big invention in 30 years
we used to innovate but over the last 30
years what can you think of that we've
actually created that's a very common
view and usually what's happening is
that it's not that we haven't invented
in 30 years it's that it takes 30 years
for us to recognize any invention so we
look back today and we're like yes the
internet was big but the internet came
about 30 years ago but if you go back to
the 1990s it was like no we really
haven't invented much in a long time
like it's always that lag in how long it
takes you to understand how big
something is going to become and you can
imagine that happening in 30 years from
now that in 30 years from now we're like
oh we haven't invented anything in a
long time but in 2024 before we came up
with the whatever it would be uh that
that is such an obvious new technology
cuz when we were inventing the car in
the airplane or the transistor the radio
or the internet very few people knew at
the time what it was going to become it
takes decades for you to understand what
it's actually going to be harder than it
looks and not as fun as it seems The
Grass Is Always Greener on the side
that's fertilized with [__] which is
a wonderful quote I can never find who
originally said it I can't take credit
for it but it's such a great quote I
think it there's a truth and life that
everything is
sales everything is sales and it's done
in an innocent way but a big part of
this is that people tend to exaggerate
and advertise what they're good at and
hide the hard Parts hide the flaws and
it creates this in this view among
virtually everybody that your success
was much easier than it was this
business is better run than I think it
is I was talking to a friend a couple
years ago who was like oh this rival
company is so much better run than the
company I work for they're so much more
efficient so much or more organized and
I'm like how do how do you know that and
and basically what it is is like from
The Outsiders perspective everything
looks like it's easier and and better
run than it actually is but if you have
The Insider perspective of how the
sausage is made you realize like how
inefficient virtually everything is and
so that's I think that's that's a big
part of life is just like realizing that
success is harder than it looks we we
talked about this earlier with Tiger
Woods Kobe Bryant Michael Jordan all
these people like if you actually dig
into what their life is it's infinitely
harder than it
looks Elon on Lex where he said my mind
is a storm most people would want think
that they want to be me but they don't
they don't know they don't understand
because what people look at Elon and
they're like oh richest man in the world
he's got a golf stream he's got big
homes I don't even think he actually
does but like he he has he's worth a
quarter of a trillion dollars you can do
anything he wants that seems like an
amazing life like no I think if you
actually dug into it I think Elon is in
like probably the bottom I'm making this
up 20% of like mental health in society
tortured you I had this uh idea called
the cookie test that I did on stage
during my live show and it's kind of
about this but from the way that we
perceive other people so imagine that
there's a cookie here and I decide that
I'm going to make the decision about
whether or not to eat it when I do that
this Unholy war begins inside of my mind
between you know there's platoon and one
of them got a dragon and there's a
trebuchet and that there's the my old PT
teacher Mr Henderson from 9 saying
you're a cookie eater and you've always
been a cookie eater and you're always
going to be a cookie eater and then
after a little while the better version
of me succeeds and I turn
away that's what I saw internally what
you saw was some bloke stare at a cookie
for a while and then turn away hungry
and sad yeah from the outside everybody
else looked like slick rational agents
and from the inside we look like
wavering idiots because the asymmetry in
what we observe of our own uncertainty
and what we perceive of someone else's
uncertainty is so asymmetric I also had
this idea about how people going through
breakups or people that feel like
they've been hard done by or maybe
they're wisting after um a friend or a
partner that they used to have and were
able to romanticize especially people
that have scorned us or that have left
us there's something sort of uh
particularly alluring in their
right um but I think it's something that
we can all take you can use this
asymmetry to your advantage as well
think about how much more deep and
dextrous and nuanced and subtle and
finessed your thoughts are than even the
person you know the best on the planet
your twin brothers thoughts are that you
know of right it's a one 10,000th one
one one millionth right of of what you
have observed of yourself
so if you are someone that's struggling
with the wistfulness and I'm never going
to be able to find anybody like them
there is also a very easy argument of
they're never going to be able to find
anybody like me yeah because you only
see this very rough Humane version of
them whereas the depth that you get of
yourself is so much greater there's also
almost the opposite of this which is
Daniel Conan's observation that it's
much easier to spot other people's flaws
than your own even though you're very
aware of what's going on in your head
and your thought process and whatnot
it's very easy for me to look at your
decisions and say like oh you're you're
you're missing this and you're
incomplete on this you're making a bad
decision here but you can justify your
own very very easily because you know
the internal dialogue in your head
that's justifying your decisions I'm
doing this because of this reason and
what not here's why I'm doing it but for
when I'm watching you I only see the
actions that you're taking and I can
just judge you much more objectively in
that measure but I think if you could
see the thoughts going on inside of
everyone else's head you would see that
the world is a thousand times crazier
than you think it is you'd see people
are a thousand times more depressed than
you think they are they're a thousand
times more creative than you think they
are they're a thousand times more evil
than you think they are because what
they're actually putting forth and
speaking and the actions that they're
taking is such a tiny percentage of
what's actually going on in their head
we had movies a long time before
neuralink or Elon Musk were really even
even sort of uh objects in the pop
culture but like Minority Report you
know the ability to be able to see what
someone is thinking or be able might be
prepared to do in future to be able to
predict that and then go after them was
it Minority Report no it wasn't what was
the thing with Tom
Cruz where they could see into the
future and he had that big
screen there's people screaming into
their iPods at the moment I don't know
but it sounds good it's great anyway
good movie my Minority Report was the
one with uh uh [__] Matt Damon right
Moran why do you spend more time
watching movies what are you doing I'm
reading books man stop it stop it um
anyway uh that's going to kill me that I
can't remember anyway that
movie The ability or what we have at the
moment people are only culpable for the
actions they take and the things that
they say not the thoughts that they have
there's no such thing as thought crime
at the moment and you can say we live in
a world that senses and all the rest
it's like yeah but if you keep your
thoughts literally as [__] thoughts
no one knows so imagine if you got
thought canceled but that's my point my
point being everybody would be cancelled
yeah
that's where the toxic compassion thing
that I was telling you about last night
comes from which I believe is
performative empathy is a front it's a
very shiny veneer that nasty people put
over the front of their meanness to
appear nice yeah it's like a small gold
bar that's being beaten so thin that
it's in gold foil and it gives the
illusion of something that's glittery
but if you poke it a little bit it's
just a hole through the other side
that's great alogy I like it incentives
the most powerful force in the world
when the incentives are crazy the
behavior is crazy people can be led to
justify and defend nearly anything I
think people underestimate the extent to
which the boundaries of their morality
the boundaries of the actions that
they're willing to take can be changed
so easily if their incentives change
mean I saw this during the financial
crisis of 2008 when people after the
crisis in in a somewhat justifiable way
would say those greedy Wall Street
Bankers who crashed the economy I'm not
saying that wasn't completely Justified
but what almost every one of those
critics didn't understand is that if
they were a
25-year-old mortgage broker at Goldman
Sachs at Leman brothers and your boss
said if you package these subprime bonds
we'll pay you $4 million this year you
would do the same thing you would have
done the exact same na concentration
camp guard but in Reverse yes yes and I
think there's so many stunning examples
of this of when the social incentives
the tribal incentives to do something
that is objectively bad but you can
easily rationalize it by being like well
this is the incentive for me to do the
right thing there was this documentary
about about El Chapo uh in in in Mexico
the uh drug lord who was a pretty
vicious terrible guy um and they're
going to this rural town in Mexico and
they love El Chapo all the people are
just like Chapo Chapo Chapo he's so
great and they talk to him and they're
like well yeah like we live in absolute
utter abject poverty and Chapel would
come in and build us schools build us
roads give us food pay for our
children's wedding we love the guy
absolutely love the guy so when the
incentives are there to overlook some
element of someone's Behavior their
personality people just suck it up right
away another stunning example of this
there's a book uh called what we know no
sorry what we knew and it interviews
German civilians after World War II and
these are German civilians who
experienced who are in Nazi Germany in
the 1940s and the the book is just
interviewing these people saying what
did you know what did you see what did
you know about the Holocaust what do you
see about what was going on and they're
interviewing this uh German civilian
woman and she says well you know when
Hitler came to power in the 1930s
everybody embraced him and the
interviewer is like why like how could
you Embrace this monster and she says
well you have to understand in the 1920s
I'm paraphrasing her the German economy
fell apart they had hyperinflation
nobody had anything Hitler came along
and said I have a better way we're going
to give you jobs we're going to give you
prosperity and the woman says in that
situation you do not say to that person
no I don't want that in that situation
where you are in a desperate situation
and someone come along and offers what
looks like help you take it and that's I
think was I think that was a very
honest description of what happened in
the situation that when the social
incentives are to embrace something that
is otherwise wicked and evil and
terrible like millions of people can
embrace it if their incentives for one
aspect of their life are are to embrace
it what about Heaven's gate Heaven gate
I think so Heavens gate was the cult
they eventually all killed themselves
they all committed suicide but there's
this amazing part of the Heaven's Gate
cult where at what point at one point in
their um in their cultish behavior they
believe that there was a spaceship that
was going to come save them come down
they could all board the spaceship
everyone else on Earth was going to die
but they would be saved they're waiting
for the spaceship to come and they go to
a store and buy a telescope so they can
see the spaceship coming in they go out
point up to the night sky looking for
the spaceship
don't see anything no spaceship they
bring the telescope back to the store
where they bought it and they said this
telescope is clearly broken it doesn't
work and the store owner says like what
what what happens to it looks like it
works to me and the Heaven's Gate guy
says it doesn't work because it doesn't
show the spaceship so it clearly doesn't
work the spaceship is obviously coming
but I can't see it so the telescope is
obviously broken like when you firmly
believe whatever kind of [__] that
you're going to believe any evidence
that's going to come that to show you
that you're wrong can easily just be
purely dismissed and that's a like a
humorous I mean it's kind of a sad
extreme example but virtually Everyone
Falls for this in some way where like if
you believe X then evidence that X is
not true can easily just be pushed away
in a second you see this a lot in the
economy we're like if you are a
pessimist and you're like there's going
to be a recession we're in a recession
and then GDP data comes out and you're
like oh it's actually pretty strong by
the way that happened this morning so
many the pessimists will be like well
you got to dig into the numbers and see
again you can easily spend anything you
want in order to justify the decision
that you've already made pessimists get
to be right and optimists get to be rich
I think that's that's by and large right
there's also a thing where a lot of
economic pessimists pundits they can be
wrong forever and they're never
penalized for being wrong because they
are giving somebody a product that they
really want and a lot of what it is is I
think at its core I think there are a
lot of people in the economy who are
feel inadequate about their own position
in the economy and and they literally
fantasize about other people suffering
economically a transfer of wealth from
the people who you have to the people
they fantasize about a stock market
crash because if other people got poor
they would feel better about their own
situation and I think that is why
economic pessimism in the punditry space
is so like when it comes out people are
like yes that's what I want like tell me
the economy is going hell makes them
feel better about their own situation
now you get it nothing is more
persuasive than what you've experienced
firsthand I read this thing this is a
pretty common that in military boot
camps this was during World War II but I
think it applies to to to any era there
would be so many soldiers who after boot
camp would be filled with bravado and
they'd be like I'm going to go get those
Nazis like when I get out there I'm
going to come guns blaz and like watch
out here we come and then the moment
they are put on the front lines and a
bullet whizzes over their head they are
terrified out of their minds there have
been some studies that showed and
they're very controversial about whether
this is actually true that only a small
fraction of the soldiers on the front
line ever fired that gun pulled their
trigger so many of them and who's to say
it would not be me or you either I can't
remember what it's called there's a a
particular type of firing that it's like
non-mortal firing or something like that
so they would do it but they'd fire just
in the air in the air because they
couldn't and over the top and I do not
this is not a criticism in the slightest
that even when you're facing a Nazi
Soldier Japanese soldier whatever it
would be to stick your gun at him and
pull the trigger you just say I don't
have it in me I can't do that I that's
not I think there's a very good chance
that I maybe you would fall in that
situation too so this is one of the
interesting I guess incentives going
back to one of the lessons we learned
about earlier on of
War yes it would be hard especially if
you hadn't gone through the training but
then you go through the training which
is basically trying to remove the type
two thinking and just put you in type
one like you see enemy bang you see
enemy bang like it's not person it's
response right they're trying to drag it
out of that deliberate thinking into
that responsive thinking but kind of
like the ever escalating ladder of
nuclear weapons that you were talking
about before if my friend that I've been
through boot camp with just gets shot
and is either dead or injured that's
going to be pretty motivating for me to
think first off I'm in that kind of a
danger and it's either them or me and
secondly [__] you you just shot my
friend yeah so you get this almost I I
would guess if you could track this if
you could study this appropriately I bet
you will find the uh lethality and rate
of firing of soldiers on the front lines
will probably follow a U-shaped curve
yeah there will not be some then people
will begin to die threat will begin to
increase people will begin to fire more
and more and more and more and more and
more and then it will tail off on the
other side and at some point and this is
a Nuance that maybe doesn't even matter
but you're not firing to kill the enemy
you're firing to save yourself it's just
like you're in a situation where it's
like it's either you or me and I'm not
and this is not about like the strategy
of what we're doing this is just a pure
survival mechanism right now but I think
I think the the broader point is like
you do not know how you're going to
respond to a situation until you've
experienced firsthand and the military
is an extreme example but this is true
for like bare markets in the stock
market so common for people to say if
the stock market fell 50% I would view
that as an opportunity I would back up
the truck and buy more and then it
actually happens and they're like oh
this sucks I'm terrified I don't want
anything to do with this it's like way
easier to quote war and Buffet than it
is to
take in theat of the moment a lot of
this is because if I were to say how
would you feel if the stock market 50%
by and large you imagine a world in
which everything is the same as it is
today except stocks are 50% cheaper yeah
and in that world you're like oh it's
great it's an opportunity but the reason
the market might fall 50% is because
it's a pandemic there's a pandemic
there's a terrorist attack and in that
situation you're like how would you feel
if the market fell 50% because it's the
day after September 11th and everyone on
TV says there are more attacks coming
that are going to impact you in that
situation you might be like that's not
such an opportunity anymore that's
always what
happens time Horizons saying I'm in it
for the long run is a bit like standing
at the base of Mount Everest pointing to
the top and saying that's where I'm
heading well that's nice now comes the
test you see this so often of like
particularly in investing but this
happens in a lot of areas in life where
people are like I'm a long time I'm in
it for the long term I'm a long-term
investor you're like great it's a good
mindset but the long term is just a
collection of short terms and you need
to experience all like all of those
short terms so a long-term investor does
not get to ignore the short-term
volatility the short-term recessions the
short-term bare markets you have to
experience and endure all of those so I
think in investing very often saying
that you are longterm is a cop out to
saying I I don't need to to to like
manage my behavior and my expectations
over the next 12 24 36 months when you
do a lot of this too is like maybe you
the investor the fund manager is a
long-term investor but are your clients
is your spouse are they going to put up
with having a shitty year maybe you're
willing to do it but is your business
partner willing to do it like saying
your longterm is very different than
actually being a long-term
person how can people make the long run
easier if there's so many you are Mr
compounding right if there are so many
gains to be acred by playing long-term
games with long-term people and
long-term investment and piecing into
the S&P and not being that fussed about
what happens and looking at signal not
noise and all the rest of it how can
people improve their long-termism and
one of the things like one of the ways
I've subtly changed how I think about
investing over the last couple years is
the a bigger realization of how much of
successful investing is nature nurture
leaning towards the nature side I think
some people are just wired to get it and
some people are not Charlie Monger made
this point where he says when young
people learn about investing they either
understand it instantly or never at all
and it's one of those two I think that's
a little too black and white but I think
he's directionally correct that some
people just get it you and I were
talking last night about like what is
the genetic soup that you're born with
you have no control over it but yours is
different than mine it's different from
everybody's and so I think some people
are much more able to think longterm
than others I'll tell you a little story
my brother-in-law is a social worker
works with very impoverished families
homeless families children who are in
terrible situations and he was talking
to this family one at one point um a
very impoverished family and he said
something along the lines of saving your
money for the next week or the next
month and they laughed at him and they
said oh you're a future thinker and he's
like what and he said you're a future
thing they said you got to understand
when you're in our situation you do not
have a Time Horizon that exists Beyond
24 hours there's no such thing as next
week we don't know where we're going to
get dinner tonight we're not there's no
next week we're just like
our field of vision is 24 hours and I
think that's an extreme example but
there's a lot of people like that of
like when if you say like oh you should
invest for the next 30 years they
literally cannot Envision what next
month is going to look like so why would
like NE 30 years is completely and
utterly theoretical for them who was
that actress was it like Margo Robbie or
someone that said we're going to be
married forever I can see us being
together for at least 10 years and then
got they got divorced next month that
was Elizabeth Taylor of her one of like
a dozen of divorc that she got where she
says like yeah there's no world in which
we're ever going to get divorced and she
gets divorced 30 30 days later um so I
think I think it's yeah it's you know
people there's a thing in Psychology
called the end of History illusion where
people are very aware of how much
they've changed in the past but they
completely misunderestimate how much
they're going to change in their future
so if you compare Chris today to
18-year-old Chris you're like H
completely different but if I said who
is Chris going to be at age 60 most of
the time you're going to be like oh
probably very similar to who you are
today and that's not true it's never
true for anyone Chris at age 60 is going
to be maybe as different as a difference
between you and 18-year-old Chris but
it's very hard to come to terms with
that most people think they're going to
be the same person for the rest of their
life even if they know how much they've
changed in the past so it's easy to say
I'm going to be married to this person
forever I'm going to be a long-term
investor forever but things change like
what you want out of life changes your
wisdom changes your incentives change to
push you to do something different the
converse is true when it comes to
personal growth as well that if you ask
yourself what would you tell you from 10
years ago you could go back in time and
write them a tweet or send them a text
or whatever what are the things that you
would tell them to start doing and stop
doing and focus on and let go of a lot
of the time people use that as a it's a
subtle brag to Humble brag about these
are the things that used to be a malady
for me but now I've transcended yeah
I would wager that at
least 70% of the things that you in 10
years from now would tell you today are
things that you today would you tell
would be things that you would tell you
10 years ago it's more just like a wish
or a fantasy of like I wish I wish I
knew this 10 years ago but frankly like
do I actually even know it today I I I
wish I could accept this truth today
frankly I still have a problem with it
you are your patterns and they continue
to repeat yeah and you you the common
denominator between all of the different
situations that you end up in is it
that every single girl is a bitter
spiteful [__] that always wants to try
and ruin your reputation all the rest of
it's like well what do all of those
girls have in common with each other the
only thing that they have in common with
each other they knew you is you you're
the only common denominator pieces
together yeah either that you chose them
or you created them or you molded them
or you did something but it's [__]
you there's some other cor where it says
something like if you meet one [__]
you've met one [__] if you meet an
[__] every day you're the [__]
you're the [__] if everyone you meet
is a jerk like this should be telling
you something yes trying too hard there
were no points awarded for difficulty I
think it's it's true like like in almost
any Endeavor there's going to be a very
small handful of variables that drive
the majority of your returns it's true
in business careers investing
relationships and and I mean it's
definitely true in investing in
particular that in in in many Endeavors
in life if you want to get better at at
golf you should you should practice a
lot if you want to get better at
basketball you should practice a lot if
you want to get better at investing you
should do less you should not you should
not practice more you should not try
harder you should not pull more levels
or levers or turn more knobs you should
do left there are no points awarded for
difficulty and it is so counterintuitive
in investing that the smartest people
who went to the best school schools who
have the best education are the ones who
try the hardest and very often earn the
lowest returns uh there was this thing
um that I read recently that as recently
as a hundred years ago the people who in
society who had the worst medical care
were the richest people the rich they
were [__] with it too much because
they they could afford all the miracle
cures sold by quack doctors that were
actually just going to poison you and I
think there is a perfect Cory with
financial advice that some of the people
who get the Financial advice are the
richest people who can afford the
highest pric consultants and advisers
that tell them to justify their fee to
turn the knobs and pull the levers and
Fiddle with the system as much as you
can to earn higher returns those are the
people who 95% of them or more are going
to underperform the simple basic Index
Fund one of my favorite Rory suland
stories was uh Terminal 5 London Heath
row you'll have been through it if
you've ever flown International
connecting through London you go in and
and you go up this escalator set of
stairs after that there's like one bloke
checking everybody's tickets it's insane
and then you go upstairs and you're at
the top gang level of Terminal 5 and
you're in a snake queue and you need to
get rechecked to go through security
and they were getting complaints there
were too many complaints the amount of
time that people were waiting they were
missing flights and and and they just
couldn't deal with it so as always they
the humans of this situation look did it
like an engineering problem it's an
optimization problem let's get retrain
the staff to be quicker can we fit more
Lanes in can we change the machines so
that the machines move more quickly can
we do all the rest of this stuff and
either Rory or one of Rory's friends
stepped in and said before you drop 50
mil on this you know two football pitch
sized area of security machines just
let's see if we can find a a behavioral
solution to this and sure enough they
did and they just put signs along the
queue that said 15 minutes from this
Point 30 minutes from this point 45
minutes from this point and all of the
signs were 5 minutes longer than the
wait time make it easier for people to
adjust their expectations and they just
got there and they were like I mean it's
40 minutes but you see it was supposed
to be 45 this was the biggest thing with
going to come Friday and they always did
it intentionally Amazon does this well I
know this because I've been so uh in the
mix with it with with Book Sales right A
lot of times on Amazon they will
intentionally quote you a ship date that
is way longer than they know they can
get it to you because they're always
just managing your expectations and then
when you get it earlier you're stoked
and almost never it will happens the
once in a while but very rarely will
Amazon quote you a ship date and then it
comes later than that because they know
even if it's one day late you're livid
if it's two days early they a custom for
Life what are the areas in which trying
harder or touching it more like with
with investing touch it less is kind of
the the rule yeah don't don't stop
[__] with it right you're an 1850s
person at the doctor just stop [__]
with it I think I think if the Endeavor
is technical then you need to mess with
it more Tiger Woods can hit a ball
better than you and I because he knows
how to angle his shoulder and swivel his
hips in whatever way that lets do it
that you and I can't investing is
behavioral so there's no there's very
like what really matters is like can you
leave it alone do you have the patience
to leave it alone do you have the
fortitude to endure the volatility it's
pure behavioral it's not a technical
thing to do so I think whenever the
Endeavor is technical you need to try
harder when it's behavioral you need to
try less why I think in many ways
relationships are behavioral as well and
if you wake up every morning you're like
I need to make a list of all the ways
that I can become a better boyfriend a
better husband like you're probably
trying too hard it's probably just a
behavioral just like can we just focus
on like respect admiration like very
simple behavioral things that are
actually going to move the needle not
like a list of the best presents that my
wife is going to want for Christmas
that's trying too hard why are we so
seduced by complexity what makes it so
attractive to us I think very often it's
the only signal that the other the
person who's trying to help you the
consultant the financial adviser knows
what they're doing and every like it's
very clear in investing in finance that
simple works like lowcost Index Fund Buy
and Hold It works but you as a financial
adviser you can't make a living saying
that you can't charge people a high fee
for doing that if you charge a high fee
that you need to do to run your business
you have to be able to say here's this
black box that I created and it's worth
the fee because it's so complicated and
this is why I think a lot of people in
finance 2 use jargon that's completely
unnecessary and a lot of academics use
jargon that's completely unnecessary
because Simplicity is so synonymous in
people's heads with you don't know what
you're talking about um and it's pretty
rare that you have someone like Warren
Buffett let's say who talks very simply
is very simple and when he explains what
he does and is and is crazy successful
as well it's usually like the lawyer the
financial advisor heon sometimes the
doctor is uh and I think it's innocent
they're not they're not you know trying
to pull the wool of your eyes it's an
innocent way that they're doing it but
they're trying to justify their
education their intelligence and their
fee with complexity yeah simpleness is
indistinguishable from cluelessness I
mean it's very rare that you would have
a Healthcare company that it's like why
don't you eat some vegetables and go for
a run like they want to make it more
complicated and sometimes the complexity
is necessary I'm not saying it's it's
always bad but the difference between
giving advice that is good and works and
running an advice business can be a mile
apart things that you don't understand
create a Mystique around people who do
understand it as well yes if I convince
you that I know something that is so
complicated that you can't even
understand a single word of it you're
going to look at me or look at whoever
it is and be like oh my God you hear all
the words he said all those acronyms I
experienced this firstand many years ago
when a family member of mine I
accompanied her to uh a meeting with her
financial adviser and this family member
does not have a background in finance
and she sits down and the financial
advisor I'm sitting with her and the
financial adviser mentions something
about the yield curve and this family
member just nodded her head and moved
along and I remember thinking to myself
she does not know what the yield curve
is she has no clue what the yield curve
is through no fault of her home it's not
a simple topic but the financial adviser
I think maybe innocently too you Pro you
know probably thought to himself like if
I talk about the yield curve I'll look
really smart I'm like I know what I'm
talking about even if the person on the
other end but the person on the other
end is like oh he said something I don't
know that's why I pay this guy he knows
things that I don't and so it's like an
intentional confusion it's that reliable
signal of effort as well that we were
talking about before it's the person
whose slack response time is always
under 15 minutes s to be online at 3: in
the morning who always gets the
but that's not always the highest point
of contribution and in fact it can get
in the way of being the highest point of
contribution yeah I mean if you let's
say you have like a a lump in your body
and you're like oh this might be cancer
and you go in and get it x-ray get an m
whatever and the radiologist goes he's
slacking his chair and he looks at the
X-ray and he goes you're fine get out of
here do you trust that guy I think what
you want is someone who's going to spend
an hour like with all of his tools
measuring things to make it look like
you really put some effort into this so
like very often effort is the only
measurement that we have complexity is
the only e measurement that we have to
say like this person knows what they're
doing wounds heal scars last what have
you experienced that I haven't that
makes you believe what you do and what
would I think about the world like you
do if I experienced what you have I
think it's so often in finance and
politics in a lot of areas in life where
people who are debating a topic uh about
what you should do with your money or
who's the best politician they're not
actually debating they're people with
different risk tolerances different time
Horizons different experiences talking
over each other so if you say just
making this up Tesla is a good
investment and I say no it's not we
might not actually be debating with each
other it might be that you have AER
higher risk tolerance than I do and so I
think when you realize that like we're
all just mirrors of the experiences that
we've had in life and I've experienced
something very differently than you have
even if we're both white men roughly the
same age you grew up in the UK I grew up
in California I experienced things that
you didn't and vice versa and even if
we're very similar in so many regards
you know things about how the world
works that I don't and I and vice versa
and it's true for every single person
and so like the idea that um if I I
think it's a really good question to ask
who would I be and what would I believe
if I were born to different parents if I
was born in a different generation if I
was born in a different country and it's
impossible to answer those questions you
don't know for any Precision but it's
important important to realize that if
you were not born where when and to whom
you were actually born to you would be a
completely an utterly different person
and you see this a lot um one thing
that's really interesting is that uh the
German stock market um has actually
performed like very well since since you
know since the end of World War II it's
actually done very well but a lot of
German investors want absolutely nothing
to do with it um and and you compare
that to American investors who are like
stocks stocks stocks it's like they they
they can't get enough of the stock
market and a lot of why that is is
because well what happened to the German
stock market in the 1940s went to zero
got completely wiped out and the
people's grandparents or their parents
who experienced that like that left a
social scar that was even passed down
through the generations so if you look
at a German investor compared to an
American investor you might be like man
the American investor is like man
they're all in this like these guys are
gunning for it and they're going to
become rich and you guys are hanging out
in bonds like what are you doing it's
just because they experienced something
that you didn't and vice versa another
example Australia before Co went almost
30 years with no recessions like a full
generation never experiencing any
economic decline a lot that was because
China had so much demand for like the
iron ore that they were digging up but
because of that in the United States
during that period we had three
recessions two of which were like
devastating and reshaped Society so to
an American a recession was a very real
thing to an Australian it was like a
theoretical possibility and the
Australians of course are just as smart
as us they have the same textbooks the
same data but they viewed economic risk
completely differently than we did and I
think you could say in that moment were
the Australians oblivious to recession
risk or are Americans overly paranoid
about it there's no one right answer all
you can say is like we've experienced
very different worlds we have very
different takes on life what's the
difference between wounds and scars uh I
think a lot of it is wounds heal in the
I made this analogy of like if you go to
uh the Pentagon in Washington DC there
is no sign of September 11th of the the
plane that hit the building they rebuilt
it there's not a single scar of it
anywhere but if you go to Reagan Airport
one mile away the the wounds oh pardon
me the scars of 911 are everywhere take
off your shoes take your toothpaste out
of your bag take your belt off going
through security all of that is a a scar
from 911 so a lot of times like the
physical damage of a recession or a
pandemic or whatever it is like heals
very quickly um but the psychological
trauma is going to leave a scar forever
you saw at the end of World War II like
Europe was rebuilt very quickly the
physical scars of the war were gone in
20 years or so but the psychological
trauma of the people who experienced
that will never go away and this was
measured in in the children who grew up
in Germany in the UK and France during
World War II what was the psychological
trauma that stayed with them through
adults was very measurable compared to
the children who didn't say in the
United States where they was not
physical destruction so even if the
physical destruction is rebuilt the
scars last forever and I think it's just
the acknowledgement that we all have
scars in one way or another from what
we've experienced in life and my scars
are very different from yours I had a
conversation with a historian of
existential risk so he was looking at
how scientific knowledge had progressed
over time and how Humanity's awareness
of our ability to go extinct through or
not through our own hands developed and
he taught me this term called conceptual
inertia which is
um you even bring it up in same as ever
where you say uh there are murmurings
amongst some of the scientists that
maybe the Earth isn't at the center of
the solar system but most of them are a
little bit scared to do it but even
after it was proven and accepted and
people were stopped being burned at the
stake by the church for suggesting that
this was the case it still took like two
generations for that to
actually Infuse into the scient ien ific
discourse why well because of conceptual
inertia because assumptions about the
world move very slowly MH culture is
able to sort of adapt quite quickly but
when it's a foundational thing it takes
a very long time you also have to wait
for the generation who who expected it
to die and it's it's a constant it's
like the the max plank quote like
science does not progress by new
discoveries it progresses when the old
generation who used to believe something
eventually dies and the new generation
who didn't come up with the old
is now in charge you tweeted a little
while ago that there are 13 divorces
among the 10 richest men in the world
seven of the top 10 have been divorced
at least once what's the lesson to learn
from that one it's a very small sample
size this is not like you know like
hardcore statistics but a variable that
is so important to your lifetime
happiness like whether or not you get
divorced among a group of people who are
so admired by Society oh I wish I could
be one of the richest people in the
world has always been so fascinating to
me and to me this is just like the scene
versus the Unseen or what you're paying
attention to when you look at one of the
richest men in the world you look at
their net worth and you fantasize about
what it would be like to have that much
money to have planes and Yachts and
mansions what you don't see for a lot of
those people and like it's it's it's too
firm to say this is pure cause and
effect but a lot of those people were so
focused on their career a singular Focus
for their entire life seven days a week
for decades on end of of of of attention
on their business that came purely
Direct at the cost of their personal
life the relationships with their
spouses with their children with their
friends whoever it would be and so this
is another of like careful what you wish
for and that there's a cost of
everything that's so easy to ignore the
most valuable personal finance asset is
not needing to impress anyone I mean so
much of spending in our society after
basic needs are met and after things
that actually impact you are are met is
spending money to show other people how
much money that you have most of whom
are strangers who are not even paying
attention to you to be with I heard this
this structure that I thought was so
good it was a high-end Toyota is a nicer
car than an entry-level BMW yep or you
could also say a sweet at the Hyatt is a
nicer room than a basic room at the Four
Seasons there's various ways that you
could spin this and I think a lot of
what it is is the high-end Toyota is
filled with things that are good for you
comfy seats good sound system moonroof
whatever it is the entry-level BMW is
purely bragging rights you're paying for
the emblem that's all you're paying for
to show other people like look at me
look how great I am if you can just
dispose of that in your life with the
need to impress strangers outside of
your core family friends co-workers
whoever it might be who like want you to
be a good person if you can dispose of
that I think that is a financial asset
on your balance sheet that could
literally be worth millions of dollars
to you just just lacking the need to
impress strangers I think that there is
a genetic set point for materialism
everything's genetically heritable from
our parents around about 50% of
everything we are psychologically is is
is inherited from our parents and
whatever combination of the hexico Big
Five personality traits contribute to
materialism Keeping Up With the Jones is
how much do I believe that love is shown
through gifts how much do I think that
it's important for me to give and
receive gifts etc etc um and I would
100% agree with you
that the people for whom your next book
is written and the people people for
whom die with zero by Bill Perkins is
written
yeah in many ways have different
challenges that they need to get over
the scarcity mindset and a concern and a
discomfort about upgrading spending with
their lifestyle and and and a fear about
getting it wrong and all the rest of it
but you can also see it as a huge
competitive Advantage because the total
amount of money that you need to meet
the standard of living that you want to
I'll never forget this dude one of the
early podcasts I did with Yousef and
John
and we were
talking I'd love to bring this back up
to them because their business is
like 30 times bigger than it was back
then or something like that they're
making way way way way way more money
and uh I remember one of the guys
talking about like some arbitrary number
like you know after uh 150 Grand a year
you're like I don't really know what
like what do I do with that like what am
I going to do buy a nicer coffee and it
was that sentence what am I going to do
buy a nicer coffeee yeah that's good
just really hit it home and I was like
well what you're doing is and we talked
about this last night and you're also
talking about it with the with the BMW
thing the difference between flying
coach and flying business is [__]
massive yes it's absolutely ginor it is
double the cost maybe if You Buck it in
advance something five times nicer in an
international flight no comparison but
the difference between business and
first is maybe another two or three
times it's bragging right the cost but
yeah it's the fact that in business
people have to walk past you to get to
economy in first you don't even see them
that's what you're going to pay $5,000
for I got to tell you this so Michael
Easter's most recent book The scarcity
mindset the scarcity effect did you see
that thing in there where uh planes in
which the people going to economy have
to walk through business have a nine
times increase in
passenger uh like complaints and
argumentation it's such a distinct like
they call it like the
the the poverty parade of like when
coach has like walked past and I think I
think there there there's some comedian
I forget who it was but like uh it's
like when when the people are walking
past People In First Class the first
class people are like man sucks you
couldn't have worked harder you could
have been sitting up here and it's like
yeah it's such like a like a pure
stratification of in society I had this
interesting realization recently too my
father-in-law my wife's father grew up
in abject poverty he was homeless for
some part of his childhood and then
became a very successful businessman
when my wife was 17 and thinking about
going to college her dad who was by then
a successful businessman said pick the
most expensive school you can find and
to him it didn't matter about the
education What mattered was showing
himself what he had overcome in life
that to him going from homeless to being
able to send his daughter to whatever
the most expensive School in the country
was he didn't know what it was he didn't
care what it was that to him meant so
much to him as a s symbol of what he had
overcome it's the I think a lot of
spending is like that it's a symbol to
yourself of like I used to be this but
now I'm this yeah well I think that's
you know apart from the people who
genuinely adore watches that's what a
lot of watches are to people it it is a
very ostentatious display of signal it's
just a super super strong signal um talb
and I think you resurfaced this Talib
quote the world is split between those
who don't know how to start making money
and those who don't know when to stop so
good phenomenal framing but I think that
there is an equivalent twist when it
comes to people who do personal growth
the world is split between people who
don't know how to change their lives and
the people who don't know when to stop
know to stop and they applies to so many
things yeah yeah um what was I going to
say I had a good one I'll teed
up valuable first uh personal finance
asset is not needing to impress anyone
no I had a great spending thing that I
was going to say anyways Morgan I
appreciate the hell out of you man
episode number five or six or something
it's honestly I said it on the first
episode people need to go and buy same
as ever I love it as a book I think it's
phenomenal it's super easy read you know
it's what's the audible 7 hours 6 hours
something like that even less and a half
or five four and a half five hours super
easy read chunked up into individual uh
chapters we've gone through loads of the
stuff today there's tons more stories
everyone needs to go and collect that
and where can they go where else can
they keep up to date with the stuff you
do most of where I am is is Twitter I'm
always going to call it Twitter X most
of where I am is Twitter in my handles
first and last name Morgan hle hell yeah
Morgan I appreciate you thanks Chris if
you enjoyed that episode then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe